hace muchos años no hay de cuantos fui a
un museo que me movió el piso me cambió
la vida era el museo de ciencias de la
ciudad de boston
entre varias exhibiciones vi una
titulada matemática el mundo de los
números más allá les confieso que yo
nunca había sido bueno para matemáticas
es más soy pésimo para las matemáticas
pero me atreví a ir a la exhibición
y les digo que por primera vez en mi
vida a los 25 años entendí conceptos de
matemáticas que en mi vida había
comprendido en el colegio y todo creo yo
porque me lo dieron en el lenguaje o me
lo mostraron en un lenguaje que yo podía
entender el lenguaje de la plastilina me
tirás el lenguaje la forma yo soy
diseñador
y creo que fue eso lo que me hizo
conectarme con el contenido a la
exhibición yo salía ya realmente como
'alicia en el país de las maravillas'
dos meses más tarde comenzó a trabajar
para una firma de diseño en washington
que se especializaba en el diseño de
museos y cuando le conté esta
experiencia mi jefe roberts tables él me
dijo césar esa fue la primera exhibición
que yo hice en la oficina de chacón
things
hablando de probabilidades
reyal films
son los diseñadores o son considerados
entre los diseñadores más importantes
del siglo 20
y ellos no me contó que matemática fue
para el mundo de los museos o es para el
mundo de los museos lo que una película
como el titanic es para el mundo del
cine la exhibición fue tan popular y tan
poderosa que inspiraba la creación de
clubes de matemáticas espontáneamente
entre sus visitantes hoy 58 años después
esta exhibición sigue mostrada en varios
museos de los eeuu
en 1995 entonces comencé a trabajar en
este mundo maravilloso los museos
él afirma de bab que creó con su socia
para trabajos que también conocido la
oficina de james california y en esa
experiencia de conocido he tenido la
experiencia de tener ha desarrollado
muchos proyectos y quiero compartir con
ustedes tres ideas básicas esta tarde y
la primera es
los museos bolsa
antes de informar o antes de educar
el museo inspira
y la inspiración es clave para motivar
el interés de alguien
en aprender algo nuevo
la inspiración
puede generar la posibilidad de una
conversación de un diálogo y por eso es
que esta idea de los museos que se
origina en el renacimiento como un
gabinete de curiosidades del mundo
natural sigue siendo relevante hoy un
museo genera la posibilidad para que la
gente con verse
con los objetos para que el objeto
convence con otros objetos y para que
los visitantes conversen con otros
visitantes
así que será pues el día de diálogo
bueno y ustedes ahora se preguntarán
bueno para que inspirar es bueno
inspirar puedes ir para muchas cosas la
primera para entender la realidad
objetiva donde vivimos o para
aproximarnos a la realidad subjetiva de
otro individuo esta gráfica que ven es
la imagen de el primer museo que se
conoce y fue creada en italia a finales
del siglo 16
y para para inspirar el museo genera
experiencias una experiencia
que toma a un individuo a través de un
camino de autodescubrimiento
la exhibición del contexto del museo
de acción y contexto del museo es perdón
es una narrativa que se vive en un
espacio y tiene un tiempo determinado es
como una especie de teatro inmersivo en
donde los individuos visitantes tú y yo
por ejemplo caminamos entre los
personajes de una historia y en donde
las barreras entre espectáculo y
espectador se borran imagínese en las
posibilidades de ese tipo de espacio
por eso la interactividad es inherente a
la exhibición
y es por eso lo que hace el museo lugar
tan interesante porque es lugar que te
pone frente a frente
con el significado que expresa un objeto
una obra de arte una escultura una carta
y par de zapatos
para la exhibición nos informamos de
todas las alternativas
también nos apoyamos de todas las
disciplinas del arte y el diseño de las
ciencias sociales de las prácticas de la
restauración y la conservación
y también recientemente más importante
de las ciencias de la administración
porque los museos por lo general son
entidades sin ánimo de lucro son
entidades del estado y es importante
comprobar el impacto que tenemos en la
sociedad nos movemos cada vez se dan
cuenta de su importancia y tienen un
gran impacto en la sociedad
pero todo comienza con el diseño de una
narrativa la narrativa es esa estructura
que sostiene los personajes en narrativa
y ahora los personajes en el museo son
los objetos la función del diseñador es
darle relevancia a sus objetos es otra
vez volvemos a conversar inclusive a
veces a pelear
con la idea de que entrega a las
visitantes la idea fundamental detrás de
una exhibición
y recuerden que un museo
dice por lo que exhibe y también por lo
que no exhibe
después nos apoyamos de la adicción que
la adicción es el es lo que le viste
realmente a la trama es la posibilidad
del diseño en la divisional a donde la
iluminación al agua de color la textura
y por último una cantidad de aspectos
técnicos porque van a tener una
exhibición con objetos de gran valor
tiene la gran responsabilidad de
proteger de esos objetos
en esta exhibición por ejemplo en un
museo en austria nuestro nuestro él y
nuestro responsabilidad o nuestro
mandato era exhibir o explicar esta
colección de armas y armaduras
considerada una de las nuevas
conservadas de europa cuando comenzamos
a trabajar en la exhibición nos dimos
cuenta que hay un problema y era que
este museo no tenía una colección de
objetos del enemigo y porque el enemigo
importante puesto que ésta era un
arsenal porque se construye un arsenal
la función del diseñador es anticipar
las preguntas del visitante entonces
convencimos al museo para que incluyera
esta parte de la exhibición y aceptaron
en ese proceso de investigación
encontramos cosas fascinantes la primera
era que a través no tenían ni un solo
objeto enemigo la segunda era que
descubrimos como un imperio
creo una estrategia de terror para
atemorizar a sus súbditos para
convencerlos de que las almacenan
necesarias
dice que la historia no se repite pero
rima
las personas que montan exhibiciones o
entidades que montan exhibiciones tienen
realmente o deben tener la universidad
ética qué significa hablar de la
historia aquí vengo a mi segundo punto
esta tarde un segundo principio es que
para que una exhibición para que una
experiencia sea convincente tiene que
revelar evidencias y muchas veces esas
evidencias son contrarias tiene que
incluir diferentes puntos de vista
porque si no es propaganda
y le voy a contar una historia de un
lugar de los estados o sea de un museo
pero empecemos primero con un poquito de
contexto el aire la pascua existen estos
no hay como aire son estas gigantes de
piedra que es un producto de una
sociedad que casi se extingue los moai
representan líderes ancestrales de la
cultura rapa nui
cuando el explorador james cook llegó a
esta isla en 1734 encontró a todo los
moais mensuales
derivados
el colapso ecológico
como producto de la tala indiscriminada
de árboles creó grandes conflictos
asociadas rapa nui
ya a punto de extinguirse por la palo y
tuvieron que crear una nueva religión
y una nueva estructura política
s
el amigo robado que está en este momento
en el museo británico en londres
pierde por completo su significado en la
interpretación que hace el museo el
texto no creo que lo pueda leer pero un
texto que no habla de lo que les acabo
de contar
las marcas que tienen más en la parte de
atrás
revelan
es la transición
del culto al hombre ancestral al culto
al nombre pájaro
este es el único modo hay de los 900 que
existen que tienen estas marcas y me
preguntó
o le saque una pregunta que nos puede
enseñar hoy una escultura construida
hace 900 años en una ciudad como londres
en un momento donde el planeta enfrenta
una situación similar
yo creo que los museos
tienen la gran misión y gran
responsabilidad
de interpretar sus objetos y eventos y
eventos históricos a la luz del presente
para que sean relevantes a nuevas
generaciones o sino el museo pierde una
oportunidad muy grande
y hablando de eventos históricos
el 11 de septiembre de 2001 yo estaba
viajando a la ciudad de nueva york
cuando mi avión aterrizó en miami a las
11 de la mañana el mundo que había
dejado en bogotá a las 8 había cambiado
por completo
yo no fui testigo de esa tragedia
pero siento que lo fui
por las memorias de las miles de
personas que fallecieron
personas que las sobrevivieron
y por el hecho de que este fue uno de
los eventos más documentados de la
historia reciente se estima que una
tercera parte de la humanidad lo vio en
vivo y en directo
ahora
un evento de terror
crea efectos
y las personas que lo sufren
para esas personas el dolor es
inolvidable
el acto perdón el daño es irreparable
y el acto es realizando
y cuando estos eventos de terrores
afectan por una década por muchos años
es una ciudad es un país que queda
paralizado
ahora como como es para usarlos
podríamos decir que una forma es
apelando a la memoria
y aquí en esta historia los museos y
memoriales tienen un poder muy
importante un rol muy importante el
problema es que crear moria colectiva es
un acto muy complejo
en primer lugar
porque nadie quiere recordar el dolor
natural y en segundo lugar
porque todos que tú y yo todos nosotros
recordamos un mismo evento de manera
diferente
eso no significa sin embargo de que como
sociedad no lo vamos a hacer porque la
memoria tiene el poder de provocar actos
de provocar actos constructivos o
también destructivos
después del 2 de septiembre en nueva
york
se incrementaron los ataques de persona
fobia exponencialmente a la comunidad
musulmana los museos reaccionaron de
manera inmediata a esta situación
revelando enalteciendo las
contribuciones de esta sociedad de esta
población a la ciudad al país y a la
humanidad
el museo genera la posibilidad de
encuentro con una evidencia una
evidencia que nos ayuda a revelar la
verdad
la verdad entendida como una declaración
en proceso constante de evolución
recuerda que en el siglo 16 era una
verdad convencional que la tierra era el
centro del universo
recuerda que en el siglo 18 era una
verdad convencional
en un ser humano se le podía secuestrar
vender matar
porque tenía una piel diferente
recuerda que en el siglo 19
una mujer no pueda tener propiedades no
podía votar
en el siglo 20 la alemania
después de unos elecciones democráticas
se volvió una cultura convencional el
aniquilar a una población porque tenía
una religión diferente una identidad
sexual diferente una cultura diferente
en el siglo 20 la pregunta es
en que verdades convencionales seguimos
creyendo
y esto me trámites del punto y último
esta tarde
y un museo larreta tus convenciones
para llevarte a un nuevo nivel de
comprensión elevarte a un nuevo nivel de
entendimiento en este proceso un museo
una experiencia puede cambiar corazones
y mentes
a maya angelou se le atribuye una frase
que en mi opinión destila el reto yo
podría que tiene un museo y dice
la gente olvidará lo que dijiste
la gente olvidará lo que hiciste pero la
gente nunca olvidará cómo nos hiciste
sentir gracias
[Aplausos]